so it's been a crazy day today back to
back to back i got a call from my
publisher just a minute ago
with some good news about your next five
moves check this out
so two lists i just got your next five
moves is
officially a toronto star best seller
today reports came out it is number
three
for business and personal finance so
it's officially an international
bestseller this is canada u.s sales
don't count
and on top of that i got a report from
usa today that your next five moves is
ranked the 56th
highest selling book i'm sorry 53rd
highest selling
book in the last week in all of us so
it's officially a international canada
bestseller
and a usa today top 50 best selling
book so first of all i got to say thank
you obviously it wouldn't happen without
you and i got to tell you for me
it's most rewarding for the emails and
the letters and the videos i'm getting
from you on how this book
has made you get more clear on your next
five moves and
what's wild about this is this is just
us and canada
and obviously we don't know about new
york times yet we got some work to do
for you in new york times i think that's
next week or the following week
this is not india this is not uk this is
not south america
you know this is not central america
there's not a lot of countries in europe
or even the middle east because it's on
those lists as well but it wouldn't
happen without all of you valuetainers
around the world that made the moves
every dollar was sending videos videos
videos about
i couldn't even send all the messages
out about how many guys bought the books
and if you
are watching this and you're saying pat
i haven't even bought the book yet well
look
you know go to barnes and noble you know
go to amazon
go to apple go to kindle go purchase the
book
listen to the audio the audio just got a
report eight
thousand of the audio version has been
purchased
eight down nearly eight thousand in us
alone and you can't buy 50 of those you
can only buy one of those
and uh if you haven't uh go get it go
read it
and i look forward to you getting clear
about your next five moves and when i
get more good news
i'll share with you soon take care
everybody